[Musique]
notre CR ce soit Diane et Nicolas qu'on
retrouve à distance pour toute sorte de
bonnes raisons bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir alors nous venons d'apprendre
que Michael c'est bien serait selon
toute vraisemblable le nouveau PDG
d'Hydro-Québec la nomination serait
confirmée au cours des prochains jours
on nous dit que ça ne serait pas
nécessairement demain il y a Conseil des
ministres demain donc ils doivent
avaliser le choix de Michael Sebia mais
ce qu'on nous dit pour l'instant c'est
que Michael Sebia serait selon toute
vraisemblance le candidat celui qui
reste le plus grand potentiel nous
dit-on à Québec pour devenir le PDG
d’hydro-québec et succédé ainsi à se
fibrechu qui a quitté le 11 avril
dernier vos premières réactions d'abord
Diane
bah c'est tout un changement c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire donc Québec a
choisi un gestionnaire de carrière un
homme extrêmement pragmatique maintenant
ce qui va être intéressant c'est de
d'évaluer quel est son degré de
sensibilité climatique et sensibilité
énergétique on se souvient qu'il y a
quitté la caisse avant que la caisse
amorce son virage eg donc depuis
plusieurs années la caisse est beaucoup
dans une réflexion
sur la décarbonation sur ces placements
au moment où Michael s'est bien est
parti cette réflexion là était à peine
amorcée donc c'est difficile de savoir
quel est son degré de sensibilité par
rapport à ces enjeux-là ça reste un
homme pragmatique qu'il est dans l'air
du temps il doit savoir ce qui se passe
maintenant ce n'est pas un homme qui
vient du secteur de l'énergie le
gouvernement a choisi de ne pas prendre
quelqu'un qui vient de secteur de
l'énergie ce sera avoir quel impact ça
va avoir sur l'acceptabilité sociale sur
l'acceptabilité des différentes parties
prenantes donc ça s'annonce intéressant
ça s'annonce intéressant qu'en
pensez-vous de votre côté Nicolas
je trouve que c'est une excellente
nouvelle parce qu'on n'avait peur que la
personne qui succède à ce fameux poste
si important subissait énormément de
pression de la main visible du super
ministre féliben et là on arrive avec
une personne de tête une personne qui
n'aura pas peur d'aller à contre-courant
de ce qu'on lui
suggère avec énormément de gentillesse à
réfléchir une carrière quand même il
faut le noter exceptionnel
PDG de belles Canada ensuite à la Caisse
de dépôt par la suite faut pas oublier
qu'il est qu'il est sous ministre
fédéral quand même énormément de travail
énormément de responsabilité donc je
trouve que c'est je l'ai pas vu venir
franchement j'ai hâte c'est quelqu'un de
très pragmatique et je crois que en
cette révolution verte là je trouve que
c'est une personne comme ça qui fallait
non c'est une très bonne nouvelle à mes
yeux mais effectivement c'est surprenant
parce que la plupart des informations
que nous avions on nous laissait
entendre vous allez le voir vous allez
tomber en votre chaise quand vous allez
apprendre c'est qui le nouveau PDG ou la
nouvelle PDG d'Hydro-Québec on se
rappellera Diane quand monsieur c'est
bien avait été nommé à la Caisse de
dépôt il y avait eu beaucoup de
critiques à ce moment-là il y a beaucoup
de gens qui se disent pourquoi
c'est lui pourquoi cette personne-là
pourquoi on n'a pas choisi quelqu'un qui
est au Québec mais monsieur Sebia donc
vit au Québec a continué à vivre au
Québec parce que je vis en avais parlé
récemment comme sous ministre à Ottawa
il vivait Ottawa mais il vivait encore
au Québec et juste un point encore puis
je vous redonne la parole Diane dans le
budget qu'il a préparé avec Richter
Freeland on a quand même annoncé des
crédits d'impôts massif dont
Hydro-Québec va pouvoir bénéficier pour
certains projets parce que on veut
faciliter l'électrification des des
transports et l'électrification de
l'économie au Québec et partout au
Canada
mais comme une des qualités de Michael
Célia c'est un homme qui est capable de
digérer une quantité phénoménale
d'information c'est un accompagne
son cerveau à un ordinateur qui était un
ordinateur d'une grande puissance à
l'époque donc c'est un homme qui peut
digérer beaucoup d'informations
accumulées beaucoup d'informations
analyser beaucoup d'informations mais je
le répète il y a toute cette sensibilité
environnementale et un équilibre très
précaire des parties prenantes on se
souvient que notre premier ministre veut
des barrages on sait que ça se fera pas
facilement qu'on ait plus dans les
années 70 donc même si Monsieur c'est
bien est un homme qui s'est affirmer ça
reste un fonctionnaire de carrière qui
connaît l'appareil étatique et qui le
respecte donc ce sera aussi simple que
ça même si c'est un esprit fort d'aller
à contre-courant si jamais il n'est pas
d'accord avec certaines positions du
gouvernement du Québec qui sont très
affirmés en ce moment en termes
d'énergie Nicolas
je vais recommencer ce que je trouve
intéressant cependant c'est l'étape de
sa carrière ou il a pas besoin d'avoir
un autre emploi dès le lendemain s'il
fait pas le boulot là ou s'il décide de
partir c'est pas une personne qui veut
continuer pendant 30 ans à gratter à
droite pour continuer à avoir des postes
prestigieux au gouvernement ou autour du
gouvernement donc ça je trouve que c'est
une fameuse une certaine liberté
d'être de
partager mais ces connaissances son
travail sa patience et talents non je
crois que c'est vraiment bien parfait on
verra on nous dit que la nomination sera
faite la semaine prochaine
selon les informations mais compte tenu
que c'est des jeunes surprises
d'apprendre le nom de Michael c'est bien
qui c'est ça peut sortir aussi au cours
des prochaines heures à surveiller je
vous amène sur le REM de l'est j'ai
l'impression va pas être loin de Michael
Sebia quand je vous parle de ça parce
que quand même la Caisse de dépôt a été
engagée dans le premier M a été engagé
dans le deuxième aventurer et là il y a
50 personnalités montréalaise qui
veulent que le projet d'urin de l'Est
avance plus rondement il y a eu l'être
ouverte aujourd'hui on demande que le
futur train soit relié au cœur de la
ville au centre-ville et à l'ensemble du
réseau est-ce qu'ils ont raison Diane
d'abord c'est un drame qui se passe avec
le renne de l'Est et avec l'AS de
Montréal il y a beaucoup de projets qui
attendent il y a beaucoup de
développement à faire dans l'est de
Montréal et se passera rien tant que le
règne de l'Est aura pas un trajet précis
et c'est excessivement important qu'il
soit relié au centre-ville pour deux
raisons pour des raisons pratiques de
désenclavagement mais pour aussi casser
cette perception d'éloignement donc pour
que l'est de Montréal ne soit plus
éloigné et qu'on ne persoase plus qu'il
soit éloigné il y a quand même
l'équivalent de 40 400 terrains de
football dans l'est de Montréal qui ne
seront pas redéployés tant qu'il y aura
pas un système de transport structurant
il y a beaucoup d'autres possibilités il
y a 13000 cases de stationnement dans
des centres commerciaux à redéployer qui
pourraient devenir
17500 unités d'habitation donc c'est
urgent qui est un projet structural de
transport dans l'est de Montréal relier
au centre-ville la ministre ok c'est
très clair la ministre Geneviève
Guilbault a promis de faire en sorte
qu'un projet final soit ficelé d'ici la
fin du mandat en 2026 Nicolas est-ce que
c'est trop long pour les de Montréal ça
trop long
trois ans pour un projet là c'est son
papier là je ministre minimise pas
l'important c'est le travail l'immense
travail que ça nécessite mais trois ans
pour arriver avec un projet moi ça
commence à sentir le troisième lien là
on va se le dire il y a les lobbies font
leur boulot bien entendu on en a besoin
mais il faut tout faire pour pas
retomber dans cette saga sociasco qu'on
vient de vivre il faut pas construire un
rêve en espérant qu'elle monte dans le
prendre il faut s'assurer de dépenser
ces fameux milliards de dollars aux
endroits où on en a vraiment besoin avec
un même avec un REM de l'Est Nicolas qui
serait connecté directement au
centre-ville
mais je sais moi je crois que ce qu'on a
besoin dans le transport vert nous
transports collectif c'est un mix
d'offre ok c'est pas one side on peut
pas se dire bon ben on va juste
construire un renne parce que c'est
juste ça qui est qu'on a sur papier
c'est juste ça qui est financable et
puis on va le faire puis le raid va être
à moitié vide attention je ne dis pas
que le contraire qu'il ne faut pas
maximiser et offrir un maximum d'offres
en transport collectif pour l'Est de
Montréal mais peut-être soyons sages
encore une fois peut-être que c'est le
règne n'est pas la solution optimale
pour répondre à cette demande ok on va
devoir reprendre cette discussion là
parce que c'est le temps qu'on lui a
donné compte tenu de la nouvelle que
nous venons d'apprendre merci Diane
merci Nicolas on espère vous retrouver
en grande forme la semaine prochaine Top
Chef bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]